this is the galaxy s6 and this to the
galaxy s6 edge and both have a lot of
similarities they're both using higher
quality materials like aluminum and
glass and they both are using those
materials in a range of bright and
interesting colors in both phones you're
going to find the usual set of
improvements that happen every year
you're going to see faster processors
you're going to see a sharper camera
brighter more vivid displays but one
improvement really does stand out and
that is battery life in both cases you
can charge these phones for 10 minutes
and have enough power to watch two hour
movie charge them for 30 minutes and
you'll already be up to fifty percent
and you can now charge both of these
phones wirelessly of the two phones the
edge is by far the more radical one it's
curved display adds extra space to
display things like discreet
notifications and allow you to access
frequently contacted people that side
display can also discretely notify you
when one of your frequent contacts is
calling you assign them a specific color
and the phone will glow in that color
letting you know that say your spouse is
calling here's the thing about the high
end of the smartphone market it keeps
getting higher and Samsung has clearly
heard calls for more luxurious devices
and with models like these which will be
coming out in April it's obvious that
they're not seat in the market to anyone
you